[Music]
in political scandal news submitted by
hey [ __ ] podcast [ __ ] a california
congressman allegedly funded his affairs
with campaign money well good for him
why is this like whew I feel like
everyone's like yeah not so cool
politicians are hard like everyone
expects them to like use campaign money
for their personal [ __ ] yeah but what if
they have Family Values on my website on
the website okay yeah good point that's
pretty good right when they have Family
Values on their website I feel like
they're getting hand jobs like in a gas
station so this is a guy who has family
values on his website Republican
California representative Duncan Hunter
was indicted for allegedly misusing more
than $200,000 worth of campaign funds
for personal gain what is it on hookers
robbing you hookers blow alcohol bottle
service oh just a whole package I'm sure
Vegas I hope he did it right yes so
basically a bunch of court filings came
out on Monday
and prosecutors said that he spent
campaign money on weekend getaways date
nights golf outings bar tabs and uber
rides during these affairs well
overrides are kind of tax deductible but
what if he's not courting that's the
wrong word what if they're all business
meetings oh they could be mrs. me horny
so we have a friend a friend who has a
friend that's a White House photographer
okay and this guy is just packing like
you know his bags and stuff like that
and he says Bill Clinton literally
walked up to him as I hey so you that
girl flare go talk to it and give me her
number I mean I'm your friend know my
story my buddy Matt Vincent has a
photographer friend that happen to my
uncle knows a White House photographer
what that fun Jamie just utilizes
photographers I didn't came up to him
and said the same [ __ ] I was like hey
that woman right there give me your
number
it's craisins nuts are you sure yeah
Matt Vincent no but Bill Clinton you
guys aren't the only ones though that is
he's no deal just one guy
exactly like she's notorious for being
what happened for both of your stories
weird as a word for huh huh oh yeah well
right when did it happen to your uncle
and when'd it happen to your friends
friends Oh Matt told me maybe like a
year or two ago I don't know I don't
know when it happened to his friend
though mom's name's Larry downing you
can look up his White House was the same
his friend is ISM I know that be even
quieter down II speak with like a
Louisiana redneck I don't know I've
talked to him like 20 years now okay
yeah he's lives in the East Coast and I
haven't seen those guys are pros yeah
yeah so so what's interesting about all
this stuff I mean he's obviously his
wife you're standing by him
well of course man but she has to
because she was also indicted why what
was she doing [ __ ] you guys too yeah
gigolos she flipped uh she flipped
changing her plea from not guilty to
guilty and admitting in court that she
and her husband used the funds quote as
their personal bank account oh why not
trips not business meetings including
including a trip to Italy and plane
tickets for their pet rabbit thanks sir
what yeah
and that to me is the climax of the
story
rabbit rabbit with them named egg
[ __ ] weird
who does it who brings your pet rabbit
with you and who names an egg bird yes
the problem I have with this whole thing
I've never had a pet rabbit everyone has
a pet rabbit yeah I'm the weird one my
bad okay uh yeah so she clears seat she
pleaded guilty why can't she just shut
up what your husband is cheating on you
yes she's nothing by the way this is
cheating you're gonna be like oh yeah by
the way we went to Italy yeah just be
like I didn't know he was with another
[ __ ] oh sandy probably I will know them
from the American flight no crazy
maybe go ahead for their men so what do
you think she shouldn't a narc don't
know yeah what's her angle like why I
think she doesn't know jail but she
didn't she go to jail or because I'm
saying that she's free she's about to be
indicted right she's in court what yeah
you seeing criminate ourselves guilty to
a charge of confession trouble she a
politician - no okay babe if this
happened to us right yeah
exact same situation do you want me to
also plead guilty and just be like like
yeah you know I used my bank account
do you think let me help you let me help
him stay on the right platform okay
because he also had affairs with a
number of unnamed lobbyists and
congressional aides so she also pleads
guilty stands by her man damn don't you
arrangement like are we a business
arrangement like on camera we're
together but you have your gigolos I
have my gigolos is that the arrangement
well now I got my answer because now it
sounds like she's running for president
in 2024 there you go what it is could be
she's gonna be in jail is where she's
gonna be Stewart and I wouldn't be
surprised if she runs for president
Stewart can I just say that the Duncan
Hunter Duncan Hunter is a huge believer
in the Defense of Marriage Act which
defines marriage as illegal human union
between one man and one woman that's
beautiful and I think that that's a
little bit beautiful he's saying
marriage is such a solemn thing we can't
allow the gays to ruin it which I think
you agree and and Sully this [ __ ]
fine institution five such a sacred
sacred institution what broadening
access to the sacred institution yeah
over my dead [ __ ] body
yeah what are your thoughts Kingsley
girl look I think he's a mess - hit the
deck cannot is not are you just like I
don't hitting that uh-huh no no he's a
believer the Defense of Marriage oh yeah
so I thought
so I mean that's typical right that the
like super anti-gay people are just hose
that's it is that I'm just I can't get
over the way I'm sorry I just can't get
over it and I found out I wasn't a wife
yeah I found out that my husband has
spent 200 grand on other women and took
me on some raggedy $10,000 trip to Italy
with our rabbit I would be furious and I
wouldn't say [ __ ] but we went here
running for president though that matter
but this actually might be her event
because check this out
so like what if they're already onto her
and then she's like you know what I'm
gonna tell you everything I'll plead
guilty but give me a less sentence what
she did no I did I said she pleaded she
pleaded guilty to a single kind of
conspiracy but you think because I get a
lesser well that's a common theme that
says like they get like they get like a
middle guy in the Mafia right to to roll
on the rest of the members and in this
whenever there's a conspiracy you try to
get one person to roll on the other
about like six nine and he's like
ratting everyone exactly I guess it
could recall the whole organization yep
okay do we know what she does for a
living be a wife wife sit around by
herself one weekend apparently exactly I
don't care because she is guilty and I
think it's campaign money so the
campaign manager had access to that all
that money makes sense why they were on
her ass and then she took the lesson
what's even crazier about all this [ __ ]
is that Congress and this is a
little-known fact because our media just
is awesome Congress has a fund and they
regularly pay sexual harassment victims
like their aides confessional II serious
yeah yeah they have a fund that they've
had since like 1995
Church exactly so there's hush money
there's the Congress hush money yes and
it's by the way you'll be happy to know
it's paid for with taxpayer yeah
what's the hush fund called yeah one
called there's a yeah it's definitely
some sort of like political euphemism
hide my dad get this Congressional
Accountability Act Oh Patriot Act right
it's against the Patriot Act so there's
nothing patriotic about it it's like fun
spy on citizens Act that's what this is
congressional this was in 1995 and
basically it was intended to make long
neck lawmakers subject to the same
workplace laws against harassment and
discrimination is the rest of employers
so who the [ __ ] cares
and so since 95 they paid like I think
it's they should come out of the pockets
of the people that did they paid more
than 17 million since 1997 to settle
scores of workplace that's what I keep
talking about both bipartisan group of
lawmakers passed this [ __ ] why can't we
choose where our tax dollars go to on an
app like yeah like if I say like alright
I'm gonna I'm gonna spend this much
money but I want it to go only to
education yeah let's all vote on it only
to the to the waterworks to my electric
service democracy or representative
Republic film so we elect the people who
make the decisions for us because
there's no true democracy no it's it's a
it's a it's called a constitutional
represent like Republic it's a republic
so we have we vote people in to
represent our desires their you place
any country in the world the true
democracy is completely different that's
old Greece it's like Acropolis anymore I
don't think so no yeah I don't also
doesn't like this or obviously the
complete opposite I don't and I don't
believe in true democracy either cuz I
don't want a janitor making my life
decisions about economy and things like
that that's what that's the argument
behind
or us making those decisions so our site
is one of those feel-good stories how do
you guys feel about Zinn like what
they're supposed to use it on because I
don't know like what are they supposed
to use it can they even say what because
it's like if you're donating for someone
you will leave in they can technically
use it for whatever campaign they just
give us open to propaganda with their
campaigns like stop bombarding my
screens with your [ __ ] I don't know cuz
I'm not involved so I get it for the
people that are involved I couldn't you
say this is like stress relief Wow
yes oh sure baby which is just yeah back
at home I needed a [ __ ] to have a
clear head yeah I need to clear this
head to clear this head because I want
to fight for you well let me clear this
head so I could clear this head
and you want a politician with a clear
mind that only fills it up with your
policies and things that you need what
drives me crazy it's about this entire
story about the congressional fund is if
you google this stuff it's there but if
you go to Snopes
which a lot of people will lie on to
fact-check information and you say if
you if you google does Congress have a
slush fund to pay sexual harassment
victims Snopes says false they and then
they just say no it's just a fund it's
not a slush fund that has a negative
connotation to it so you're like wait a
minute this isn't you're not
fact-checking anything you're just
saying it's okay because for some reason
Snopes is running cover for this whole
thing that's weird
some guy Eggbert some guy who like
cheated on his wife and like ran away
with a bunch of hookers a couple years
ago and got into trouble but nobody
reported on that either really yeah you
can do so much conspiracies crazy